(brouhaha)
de Tétreaultville, à Montréal,
on déambule, on mange.
Rien ne laisse présager
que nous sommes à quelques
électorale.
Sauf, peut-être,sence
des candidats des cinq
principaux partis.
qui débutent demain?
- Non, pas bien, bien,
bien, bien.
- Oui, tranquillement, pour voir
ce que chacun a à entend plein
d'affaires, mais on est jamais
en sûr. Oui, je vais
suivre ça.
- Que ce soit d'un bord
déçu, donc je n'y crois plus.
- Le Québec vivra sa deuxièmemee
élection provinciale à date
fixe. Depuis des semaines,
on eend icités partisanes.
- C'est un peu longuet.
Ça aurait pu commencer plus tôt,
ça n'aurait pas fait
de différence.comm.
et président, TESLA RP
- Les él'est vrai
qu'il va falloir garder
leur intérêt, c'est vrai
travailler fort.
- Le plus grand risque,
pour les partis politiques,
c'est le désintérêt face
à la do sondages. sondages. son.
- Tout le monde, y compris
François Legault, a intéret
à ce que les gens se préoccupent
de cettepour François Legault,
de faire sortir le vote. La CAQ
a gagné des circonscriptions
par très peu de voix.
- Pour ail faudra discuter d'enx
qui les préoccupent.
- J'ai envie d'entendre parler
d'écologie, c'est sûr,
- Économie. Surtout d'économie,
parce qu'on vient de passer
une pandémie.
- Au-delà des enjeux,
s'intéresser à cette élection
llement historique :
le Québec pourrait se retrouver
en régime de parti dominant,
ANDRÉ LAMOUREUX, chargé cours,
Dép. de litique, UQAM
- Tous les autres partis
de l'opposition au Québec
ce qui fait la CAQ dominerait
comme roi et maître
dans le système politique.
- Un situation qui ne s'est
vue qu'ure de la province,
en 1919.
Ici Maraquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Mon